y
70 años de reinado de una reina tan
popular como siempre isabel segunda de
96 años apoyada en su bastón es aclamada
por la multitud frente al palacio de
buckingham la reina celebra desde este
jueves su jubileo de platino el reinado
más largo de la historia de la monarquía
británica desde la reina victoria que
estuvo 63 años al frente del imperio
británico en el famoso balcón junto a
isabel segunda su hijo el príncipe
carlos que le sucederá y su esposa
camila pero también el príncipe william
su esposa kate y sus hijos los grandes
ausentes el príncipe harry y su esposa
megan que no pudieron saludar a la
multitud desde el balcón al igual que el
príncipe andrew el hijo de la reina
acusado de agresión sexual en relación
con el caso sting a última hora de la
mañana los miembros de la monarquía
británica llegaron al palacio en
carruaje una imagen poco habitual desde
la pandemia de las tres generaciones de
la realeza juntas en un mismo vehículo
muchos fans decidieron dormir en este
centro comercial para asegurar una buena
vista
venimos de manchester y birmingham una
de mis hijas bien incluso desde parís
para que podamos estar todos juntos
llegamos a eso de las 6 de la mañana
para poder estar en primera fila y tener
la mejor vista
y estoy deseando ver a la reina en el
balcón con la familia real es la primera
vez que veo esto el heredero de la
corona el príncipe carlos reviso las
tropas en el desfile militar durante el
saludo a las banderas debido a que la
reina ya no monta a caballo aunque es a
ella a quien los británicos celebrarán
durante cuatro días más que la monarquía
lo que los británicos celebran es el
devenir de una mujer que forma parte de
su historia y de su vida cotidiana